[Music]
we always had the back of our mind as a
team we playing for the country of
Lincoln Nelson Mandela
[Music]
this is what I was wearing like an eBay
Nelson Mandela like 20 minutes before
the rebel Capano started and the awesome
Mandela walk interchange him as a big
surprise for us and the changing when
dead quiet they could yet by pin drop
and they were the youth smile in his
face he said to the team hello my fellow
staff Ricans I'm here to support you and
I want you to know that I'm a biggest
supporter today and the house had Africa
stands behind him and then he walked
around and shoot about his hand and as
to say well congratulations and good
luck for it for the game in France up in
a penis to stood up and he said today to
the team that
enough said Nelson Mandela was no change
room let's go out there and make Madiba
proud and they know what the rest was
history we won the Rugby World Cup
[Applause]
[Music]
being a rugby player as a so-called
black or colored player into that figure
was challenging time see because our
part it you know you were not allowed
for instance we go and play with him you
see sometimes have to change on the bus
because I mean he were not allowed to go
and change the aftermath functions you
would go straight on the bus and go home
because it's often it was the aftermath
function was only for whites you know
you wanted to compete anyone to prove to
everyone that you actually that we as
black people can also play rugby and be
at the best in that in that sport you
have to prove every single time why you
need to be in a team will always have
the power to unite people and to and to
bring people together everybody forget
about the politics of what they have at
home what they don't have at home they
think about the Springboks they speaking
about rugby this mean what kid just be
happy and socialize and that is what
Wragge it brings to producer Africans
[Music]